today homeland security secretary
Kirsten Nielsen went up to Capitol Hill
to share a little dose of something
called reality with Congress we face a
crisis a real serious and sustained
crisis at our borders we have tens of
thousands of illegal aliens arriving at
our doorstep every month we have drugs
criminals and violence spilling into our
country every week illegal immigration
is simply spiraling out of control now
let's break it down to the cold hard
facts in the month of February 76,000
illegal aliens were apprehended at the
border that's just the ones apprehended
a 30 percent increase from the previous
month apprehensions and from the year
before it's even worse this is an eighty
percent increase over the same time last
year and I report today that CBP is
forecasting the problem will get even
worse this spring as the weather warms
up could be getting worse well we could
be looking yes at nearly 1 million
illegals crossing our borders if the
trends continue if these numbers hold
every four months will import the
equivalent of the population of Richmond
Virginia or Baton Rouge Louisiana into
the United States and this isn't a
national emergency let's face it most
Democrats know this is a crisis the
sheer volume of crossers is overwhelming
our facilities and liberals then blame
Trump point of migrant doesn't see a
doctor immediately as with their embrace
of infanticide and reparations
medicare-for-all Democrats have gone far
far left on immigration and now they are
in effect for open borders there are
other options and Cobra said there are
other options to incarcerate and holding
everybody is thousands there there were
programs that will enable people to go
into our communities and to be able to
be tracked in our communities well sure
let's LoJack's on everyone what is that
they tracked in our communities they
already put ankle brace
it's on a lot of the illegal immigrants
and they just tear them off terrifying
that she doesn't understand the basic
facts of immigration and while we're
creating these grand new plans to hold
the legal immigrants accountable and
attract them let's not forget who's
footing the bill here guess what the
cost is eighty-two thousand dollars per
year per illegal immigrant in the United
States and then of course the children
they have and then the children are
citizens and then no one's deported
Democrats prefer to focus though on
non-citizens
their treatment their medical care there
and of course their race you wanted to
separate children and families and you
wanted to do it with compassion you have
no feeling no compassion or empathy here
white babies would not be treated the
way these babies of color are being
treated Madam Secretary this is about
color we've opened our doors your tired
your poor huddled masses yearning to
breathe free except we now have a
quarter of people of color
it gets very dramatic when you whisper
now the Democrats can't play chords they
stick to one maybe two notes and they're
always off-key well the record Madam
Secretary we still use in cages for
children I sir we don't use cages for
children in the border facilities that
you've been to they were not made to
detain children to my knowledge CBP
never purposely put a child in a cage
purposely or whatever are we putting
children in cages as of today children
are processed at the border facility
stations that you've been at some of
them obscene the cages I just want you
to admit that the cages exist sir
they're not cages well you know what
that is see it up on the screen right
there that's a so-called cage that the
congressman was referring to but that
well fed those you know kind of a
fencing thing it's a it's an enclosure
for sure was used by the Obama
administration to detain
illegal miners during their processing
until they could be placed with sponsors
now where was the Democrat outrage when
Obama was using the same fencing
facilities that liberal do-gooders now
deplore and make a big deal about it a
hearing to get on shows like this well
instead of focusing on the surge of the
border and the lack of facilities to
house the people crossing the border
Democrats are throwing sand and throwing
down the race card it's about all they
know these days when the CBP
commissioner Kevin McHale Ian testified
to the Senate Judiciary Committee that
walls and barriers in key hotspots along
the border had an immediate impact in
reducing the crossings Senator Dick
LeDoux Blumenthal he didn't want to hear
any of it numbers of border crossings
are still at a historic low compared to
other times in our nation's history
no senator they're not we're on pace for
over 700,000 crossings this year that's
closer to historic highs and historic
lows the Commissioner is 100% right over
60% of the total apprehensions along the
border are now illegal family units and
unaccompanied alien minors those under
the age of 18 and new DHS figures find
that those apprehensions of illegal
family units have surged by three
hundred and thirty eight percent but no
emergency here no crisis and the
apprehensions of unaccompanied children
are up fifty-four percent that's not
dangerous for them right no emergency no
crisis how about this because of the
increase in violence at ice when we have
families with children we have to give
every girl a pregnancy test over time
this is not a safe journey girls are
being abused raped and in some cases
trafficked as part of these caravans and
it is despicable what is happening to
these young people Congress needs to get
its head out of the sand and stop this
madness once and for all if someone
crosses the border illegally with rare
exception they should be turned back
immediately family units or people
posing his family
family units would not make this
dangerous trek once word spread in their
home country Congress should pass this
law if you want to apply for asylum
that's fine but you should do so in the
safety of your home country or as is
beginning to happen now once you're in
the United States and you declare you
should be set to Mexico until your case
comes up for hearing we have a backlog
right now of eight hundred thousand
immigration cases the current system
today it's obvious come on everybody
knows this Democrats know this it
incentivizes human trafficking the abuse
of kids and more illegal crossings
period that's why you have the big jump
any Democrat or any Republican who
refuses to act now are the ones who are
truly lacking in the feeling and the
compassion and the empathy not only for
the illegal immigrants but for the
American people they're supposed to be
representing and that's the angle